[Music]
infamous automotive mark zuckerberg has
been working overtime to bring his
metaverse dream to fruition and he's
noticed you know that our lives have
already been almost entirely consumed by
the internet to the point where most of
us are now essentially cyborgs half
robot half human except without any of
the cool superpowers that cyborgs and
science fiction usually possess in the
movies a cyborg has all of the best
qualities of humans and machines in
reality we have the worst ingredients of
both so we're fat and lazy like people
but we're also amoral and emotionally
vacuous like computers
so we're kind of like mermaids but if
the mermaid had a fish's head and a
human's body it's like the worst
possible combination
a combination more monstrous than
mythical i guess
and this is what our near total reliance
on and addiction to the internet has
done for us but mark zuckerberg has seen
all of this and determined that we still
have not invested enough of ourselves
into cyberspace and that's where the
metaverse comes in with the metaverse we
can actually enter into the internet
submerge ourselves in it lose ourselves
inside it like a like a dream a bad
dream
if you've ever visited reddit or you've
read the comments under a viral tweet or
you scrolled through tiktok and thought
to yourself wow i wish i could be
trapped inside a three-dimensional
virtual prison cell with these people
then the metaverse will be right up your
alley but if you're a sane person
you probably feel differently and yet it
doesn't matter how you feel this is
where we're headed the metaverse is it's
happening whether you like it or not and
15 years from now you'll be sitting
around your virtual dinner table
with your virtual family eating your
virtual food while your physical body is
encased in a pod and connected to wires
and tubes and you'll be telling your
virtual child who prefers to use a pep
of the pig avatar all about the old days
when the internet was contained almost
exclusively inside your phone
and peppa will laugh and say that's
silly daddy and you'll pretend to laugh
too
and nobody will be able to see you cry
because they don't have tears in the
metaverse because meta president mark
zuckerberg has declared that that
everyone must always be happy inside his
domain
anyway so the point is that that i'm not
a big fan of this whole idea but it's
happening anyway and um
and uh and though the metaverse is still
in its infancy
it has already had its first me too
moment
the new york post reports it says a beta
tester beta tester has claimed that she
was virtually groped in the metaverse vr
platform horizon worlds for meta the
company formerly known as facebook meta
revealed the incident on december 1st
saying it occurred on november 26th the
woman had reported the assault
the assault
in virtual reality on the horizon
world's beta testing facebook group
sexual harassment is no joke on the
regular internet but being in vr adds
another layer that makes the event more
intense she wrote according to the verge
not only was i groped last night but
there were other people there who
supported this behavior which made me
feel isolated in the plaza the virtual
environment's central gathering space
severe encounters of online harassment
including physical threats stalking and
repeated harassment are on the rise
according to a 2020 pew research poll
with the percentage of users reporting
such incidents jumping from 15 in 2014
to 25 today while much of it takes place
on social media vr is uh still nation
and already an apparent venue for
harassment horizon worlds operated by vr
company oculus which is also owned by
meta meta is a build built as a pleasant
productive digital escape a place to
create in extraordinary ways and find
experiences that matter with your avatar
friends
groped virtually on the internet is what
we're dealing with
and
that's a pretty serious crime we have to
admit
in fact it brings back the trauma that i
suffered as a child when i was virtually
assaulted by a south asian man with very
long arms while playing street fighter
at another point playing a different
game i was virtually cannibalized by a
huge yellow head
i have been virtually beaten shot
stabbed tortured in all manner of ways
though i suppose i'm no saint myself in
the same game street fighter i committed
virtual battery against an obese sumo
wrestler which was arguably a hate crime
as well
given that the victim was a video game
character of color but then again my
character was green so i'm not sure how
this all works uh i don't know how we
work out the intersectionality part of
that but anyway a little bit more from
the article it says in its statement
about the incident
meta pointed to its safe zone feature
which allows users to place a block
against interaction with other users
however the company admitted that it
needs to work on making the feature
trivially easy and findable
says vivek sharma the vice president of
horizon in a statement to the verge
meta spokesperson christina milion also
told mit technology review that users
are required to complete training that
covers safeguarding tools before joining
horizon world while reminders reminders
are also prompting prompted during users
experiences
sexual harassment in virtual reality is
sexual harassment in real life full stop
experts have said
quote at the end of the day the nature
of virtual reality spaces is such that
it is designed to trick the user into
thinking they are physically in a
certain space
that their ever that their every bodily
action is occurring in a 3d environment
catherine cross a phd student researcher
on online harassment at the university
of washington told
technology review quote it's part of the
reason why emotional reactions can be
stronger in that space and why vr
triggers the same internal nervous
system and psychological responses
those who have suffered sexual
harassment in vr vr elsewhere say that
meta's safe zone feature isn't enough
okay so sexual harassment in virtual
reality is sexual harassment in real
life according to experts it's the same
i wonder if they've
asked any actual real-life victims of
sexual assault you know people who've
had their physical bodies violated not
the bodies of cartoon characters on the
internet
how do they feel about this
do they agree that their experience was
exactly the same as the experience of
somebody who's fake metaverse avatar was
fake groped by another fake character in
a fake world
i'm guessing they'd say no
another big difference between real life
assault and virtual assault
these real victims might point out
is that the virtual victim can simply
turn off their headset
and the problem goes away
no such escape valve exists for the
real-life victim they might remind us
but then again you know they aren't the
experts the experts are the experts and
we know who the experts are because they
belong to a group called the experts and
the media tells us how they feel about
stuff like this and we're supposed to
nod our heads in agreement and say
nothing else
now this is all quite ludicrous of
course by definition you cannot be
groped in virtual reality because
groping is a physical act
nothing physical is occurring in that
realm
there's a there's a reason we don't
prosecute people for vehicular homicide
based on incidents that occur in mario
kart
and yet and yet at the same time
catherine cross the phd researcher
she's correct when she says that vr
technology tricks the user into thinking
they are physically in a certain space
but the key word is tricks
it's not real
they're not actually in that space
nothing that happens to them in that
space is actually happening to them it's
happening to a computer code on a screen
so one computer code is interacting with
another computer code
it feels real but it's not
but the fact that people can be fooled
in this way
you know that doesn't mean that we need
more rules or policies or regulations
or that we have to have legal
protections put in place for cartoon
avatars
now we don't need laws that will wind up
putting 12 year olds behind bars for
first degree homicides committed in call
of duty
that's not the conclusion that we should
draw from this
here is the conclusion
that the internet is often not very good
for your brain
and virtual reality will be even worse
the fact that virtual reality tricks you
and makes it hard to distinguish between
reality and virtual reality is not an
argument for treating virtual reality
like it's reality
but it may be an argument for not using
virtual reality at all
the last thing we need is yet another
tool to tear us away from our physical
existence and immerse us in a world that
is fake but feels real
that's the last thing we need
and that's the lesson here we don't need
more virtual reality we need we need
more reality reality
that's the world we should be living in
most of the time
so that's why in the end
i think the metaverse is what we have to
cancel today well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matt wall show if you
did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button right down there so you can stay
up to date on all of our future content